New York Post has this has this
article the mother of the hulking
Florida teen who beat his female teacher
unconscious over a Nintendo switch video
game claimed that prison time would be a
death sentence for her convicted son
lyanna DEA who uh pleaded for leniency
for the now 18-year-old Brendan DEA who
faces up to 30 years behind bars for
slamming uh montanza High School par
professional Joanne Nack to the floor
before kicking and punching her in the
back and head more than a dozen times
and the video of that attack you've
probably seen it we played it on the
show we don't have to play it again it's
just um a brutal Savage attack on this
woman and and thank God did not kill her
but but could have easily killed her in
her first public appearance since the
February Beatdown The Grieving mother
Wednesday begged naq to request that the
6'6 teenager be handed a lighter
punishment um but as of now the teacher
has said that she wants her attack or
sentence to the maximum of 30 years
behind
bars um here is the mother on news
Nation talking about this let's watch it
I am so sorry for what my son did and um
nobody nobody should ever have to go
through
that but at the same time please
consider that my son has had a hard life
and he's gone through so much trauma in
his life he has
autism please show Mercy to him it's
devastating that um my heart is breaking
um I'm terrified for my child I you know
I feel like if he gets sentenced to
prison it's a death sentence for him um
he's scared and to have your child call
and cry and say I don't want to
die um it's it's awful and I don't
understand why that um in his IEP it was
stated that in the Intensive behavioral
group home that he was living in if they
ever had to remove it as a consequence
they called in the crisis
team and um the original IEP called for
a token economy for um he could know to
motivate him to do his work he could
earn uh tokens to then go to like a
snack closet
um this year he had a new teacher who um
it's not Joan Joan was not his teacher
she's a parah um he had a new teacher
who um it was her first year teaching
and she didn't I don't know if she
didn't understand the IEP if she didn't
read it but she approached the group
home and asked the group home to send it
in listen for anybody who watches that
video it's it's hard for them to get P
it and I can understand they they'd be
devastated for for Joe nich the um the
victim in this in this attack and and I
can imagine you feel uh first of all so
a couple things here first of all I give
a lot of credit to the teacher for
demanding
Justice and uh maybe that seems like
something that doesn't take a lot of
Courage because well yeah you got
attacked and of course you want the
person punished but um these days it
shouldn't require courage for a victim
to demand justice but these days it does
I mean how many times have we seen
victim in these
situations disgrace themselves after the
fact by making excuses for the attacker
mean we we we we've even seen family
members of victims who were
killed turn around and say
well you know I'm sure the person who
committed the crime was disadvantaged by
the
system I'm sure they lived a hard
life I mean it's it's disgusting it's
actually disgusting
and especially from family members I I
I'm sorry you know I I know we shouldn't
judge people going through something so
difficult
but anytime you see one of these videos
like your own family member was
killed and your your first thought is
like let's be nice to
the but we know why they do that it's
it's it's bowing to uh social pressure
it's this political correctness and
wokeness that um people even in moments
of crisis
will still abide
by so I give a lot of credit to her for
not playing that game she wants Justice
she's demanding
it and she should get it as for the
attacker here you know I get why his mom
uh is pleading for Mercy I I don't blame
her really for having that
opinion um I do blame her a little bit
for putting the victim on the spot I
mean if you want to go on TV and say um
you I want my son
he's he's he's not as bad whatever you
want to go on TV and and talk about how
he's really a good kid and all the rest
of it I mean it's kind of hard to
believe but um as the mother I don't
blame you for that putting the victim on
the spot
though and saying I'm sorry this
happened to you
but like there's no butt there you you
don't you don't start your next sentence
with a
butt I'm sorry my son knocked you to the
ground and beat you s
senselessly but at the same time
even as the mom in this
situation you're still called to have
some empathy yourself so if you want to
if you want people to have empathy for
your son then you need to show some and
saying I'm sorry this happened to you
but no
but so if I was her you know you leave
the victim you don't say anything about
you you don't have the right to do that
you you just don't have the
right to call on the victim
to be nice about
this you want to call on the court
system you want to just kind of
generally Advocate on your son's behalf
I get
it but yeah in fact I do I do blame her
for
um sort of using this public emotional
manipulation against the victim
specifically you just have no right to
do
that and um whether we understand the
mother's um feeling here or not doesn't
matter because I think the answer from
the court system should be
no please have mercy on my son
no we will not have
mercy this man and he is a man he's not
a kid he's 18 now this man has to be
removed from society he has to be
segregated from civilized society he is
not fit to be a part of society he
cannot be allowed to walk free it's that
simple autistic hard life emotionally
troubled whatever doesn't
matter like I don't care actually oh my
son's autistic don't
care I would have cared before
this before he uh you know pounced on
top of that
woman and tried to beat her to death if
you had told me before that my son has
autism I would have cared I would have
been very
sympathetic but after that happens I
don't care
anymore and I know that that makes me
cruel in most people's eyes because I
know that these days you know that's the
kind of thing somebody brings up
something like this happens someone
brings up autism it's supposed to be oh
well okay well in that case
I no I don't care you should still go to
prison forever in fact 30 years I give
him I 30 years is too light I put him in
forever never to see a free never to
walk free
again because he did what he did and
that's it he demonstrated that he is a
danger to
society and that is all that matters now
are you a few years or even a few
decades out of school and wondering what
the heck did I even learn what was the
point might even be thinking I don't
have the time to learn something new
well if that's you you're not alone and
it's not too late Hillsdale College is
offering more than 40 free online
courses learn about the works of CS
Lewis the rise and fall of the Roman
Republic or the history of the ancient
Christian church with Hillsdale colleges
online courses if you not sure where to
start check out American citizenship and
its decline with Victor Davis Hansen in
this eight lecture course Victor
explores the history of citizenship in
this in the west and the threats that it
faces today threats like the erosion of
the middle class The Disappearance of
our borders the growth of an
unaccountable deep State and the rise of
globalist organizations the course is
self-paced so that you can start
whenever and wherever you want start
your free course of American citizenship
and its decline with Victor Davis Hansen
today go to hillsdale.edu Walsh to
enroll there's no cost it's easy to get
started that's hillsdale.edu Walsh to
enroll hillsdale.edu
Walsh everyone knows I love my Helix
mattress but have you checked out their
Helix Elite line Helix has harnessed
years of extensive mattress expertise to
bring their customers a truly elevated
sleep experience the Helix Elite
collection includes six different
mattress models each tailored for
specific sleep positions and firmness
references I've had my Helix for years
and I love it it's the best mattress
I've ever had if you're nervous about
buying a mattress online you don't have
to be Helix has a sleep quiz that
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
because why would you buy a mattress
made for somebody else go to
helixsleep.com
Walsh take their two-minute sleeve quiz
and find the perfect mattress for your
body and sleep type your mattress will
come right to your door for free plus
elix has a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will trust me
their financing options and flexible
payment plans make it so that a great
night's sleep is never far away Helix is
offering 20% off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for my listeners go to
helixsleep.com Walsh this is their best
offer yet and it won't last long with
Helix better sleep starts now here
here's how I look at
it either he brutally attacked the woman
because he's autistic and doesn't know
any
better which I don't buy by the way
maybe he's autic maybe he's not I don't
know the fact that that mean that he
doesn't know any better I don't buy
that but either that's the case in which
case he certainly cannot be trusted in
society ever again if you're telling me
this is a this is a a kid quote unquote
who you need a crisis management team on
staff to take his Nintendo switch
away and he's 6
foot6 right 200 plus whatever pounds and
you need to have a whole like SWAT team
on staff just to take us that we cannot
ever trust him anywhere in society
I would you want to ride on a bus next
to that guy would you want him living
next door to
you
no he's a danger to everyone if that's
how he is it doesn't matter
why if that's the case if he doesn't
know any better and he can't help it
he's a dangerous Society has to be
removed from society if he attacked the
woman
because he wanted to and and he could
have chosen otherwise but he just
decided to do it because he wanted to
well then he can't be trusted in society
ever again either way the conclusion is
the same in fact you could
argue I think quite convincingly that if
some if some kind of mental handicap
caus this that's even more reason to
permanently segregate him from society
this is what I will never understand
about the uh mental challenges
excuse cuz if it's true then that's all
the more reason why this person cannot
ever it it if they're not even capable
of understanding why they shouldn't do
that obviously they can never be trusted
in society ever
again you know if he's being driven by
forces outside of his control to lash
out violently well that's very sad but
it makes him a danger to society and we
have to respond to that danger I've said
this many times we must choose
between Mercy for innocent victims or
Mercy for violent thugs you cannot show
Mercy to both you can't anyone who tells
you you can is
lying one of the other Zero Sum game
Mercy to one group comes at the expense
of the
other so who should lose here like
someone has to
lose either we put innocent people in
danger by being merciful to dangerous
people or we punish dangerous people and
those dangerous people are going to live
terrible awful lives for the rest of
their lives I mean the idea of being
locked in a cage
for the next 30 Years is awful like it's
a it's a terrible
thing that this man is is his whole life
is wasted now it's a it's terrible it
really is it's really
terrible
um but either we say too bad to him or
we say it to uh his next
victim those are the
choices like someone gets the short end
of the stick somebody
loses and so who should lose who should
the justice system prioritize the woman
who got beat half to death or the guy
who did the
beating I mean it's not even a question
or it shouldn't be it's not it's not
even a difficult ethical people say oh
it's so difficult so many difficult
ethical no it's not it's really
easy it's it's super easy
there are a lot of emotions that are
maybe tied up in it but in terms of what
is the right thing to do really
easy the other problem with the mental
illness excuse is that literally
everyone who commits a brutally violent
crime could be or has been diagnosed
with something okay all of these people
by definition are mentally deficient in
some way a lot of them have very low IQs
a lot of them suffer from whatever
delusions a lot of them have trouble
controlling their emotions a lot of them
have trauma in their
past I mean you don't go out and commit
a barbaric crime that sure to land you
in prison for decades unless you are a
mentally Disturbed
person um and like I said even aside
from the mental illnesses that the low
IQ is is is plays a factor here you
watch any of these videos of somebody
like brutally just on camera in front of
everyone savagely beating someone in
most of those cases if you were to
measure that person's IQ it's probably
like
um and you could probably say well if
that person had like even 30 more IQ
points they they might not even done
that because they'd be too they'd be
smart enough to know that however you
are feeling you can't react that way
because it's going to ruin your
life and maybe that and that's probably
true but so
what these are crimes that by their
nature are only ever committed by people
who have to use the modern phrase mental
health
challenges and so and
okay so how does that change
anything you know um you often he hear
people say when they're calling for us
to be compassionate they say uh well put
yourself in that person's shoes you know
if you were raised that way if you were
abandoned as a child if you were abused
if you ended up in foster care you know
if you had a low IQ as I'm sure this
person does uh if you had if you were
autistic if you had right like you take
it take me and and put me ex like give
me all the exact same circumstances as
that guy everything exactly the same as
him I'd probably do what he did because
i' I'd like I'd beat him and so it
stands a reason I just since I'm him I'm
doing whatever he
does
um that to me that's like it's a truism
but it doesn't it doesn't mean anything
functionally for the justice
system because one of the primary
functions here is to segregate dangerous
people from
society that's not the only function of
the justice system it is also to punish
evil and what he did is evil and it
should be punished Autistic or
not but the other big thing is to is to
protect
society and when it comes to that
function it really doesn't
matter
why you did
it
um all that
matters when it comes to that part of it
is are you a danger to
others and if you are you you just you
cannot be a part of society it that's
it it'd be like if you said if you said
oh no don't punish that man for stealing
you don't understand he struggles with
greed he's very greedy that's why he
stole he struggles with
it yeah we get that kind of picked up on
that based on context clues that's not
an excuse though it's just like a
description hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there